en direct touche pas mon poste et Gilles
alors pendant le pendant la la pause là
il y a beaucoup de gens qui vous
demandent des explications qui sont un
peu choqué par ce que vous avez dit
puisqu'on vaevoir le tweet de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a été non pas celui-là ils
comprennent rien aujourd'hui voici la
France pendant ce temps Madame Bron pivé
camp à télaviv pour encourager le
massacre pas au nom du peuple français
est-ce que les propos de Gill ont choque
autour du plateau Jacques moi ça me
choque terriblement je comprends pas que
tu puisses dire toi Gilles Verdez que le
mot camp ne te choque pas le camp ça
renvoie directement au camp de
concentration c'est un mot qui n'est pas
choisi au hasard parce que vous l'avez
dit Monsieur Mélenchon est quelqu'un
d'extrêmement intelligent tribain et ça
sa sa tactique est une tactique qui
consiste à placer des mots de façon
insidieuse et de de de d'alimenter de
décomplexer de libérer une parole
totalement antisémite l'antisémitisme de
gauche c'est quelque chose qu'on connaît
depuis 150 ans et puis il y a un
antisémitisme aussi assez populaire pour
vous Jean-Luc Mélenchon il est
antisémite moi j'aimerais aujourd'hui je
voudrais demander aux deux hommes
politiques qu'on a sur ce plateau
pourquoi il ne porte pas plainte contre
Monsieur Mélenchon puisque en effet
Valérie l'a dit tout à l'heure il n'a
plus de mandat donc il n'est plus
protégé par l'immunité d'un
parlementaire comme vous monsieur moi je
pense que il y a un moment donné où il
faut passer à l'action judiciairez
travailléardo qu'est-ce que vous dites
là de ce que toutes les sorties de
Jean-Luc
Mélenchon je crois que c'est la dernière
manifestation de l'effondrement moral de
Mélenchon et de la direction de la
France
insoumise dernière manifestation après
ce qui s'est passé le 7
octobre les attaques terroristes du
Hamas massives d'une monstruosité absolu
contre des Israéliens des civils des
femmes des enfants de vieillards faut-il
encore le rappeler et je crois que c'est
un effondrement moral parce que quand un
homme qui était attaché à la République
qui venait du camp de la gauche n'est
pas capable de qualifier les faits et
qui en plus avec ce dernier tweet montre
toute sa capacité
chirurgicale de jouer sur tous les codes
de l'antisémitisme je considère que là
il y a une barrière de principe qui a
été franchi et cette fuite en avant de
Jean-Luc
Mélenchon peut s'expliquer d'après une
certaine logique même si on n'est pas
obligé d'aller jusqu'au bout de
l'ignomini comme il le fait
et c'est que il a choisi une stratégie
c'est celle du populisme et de la
radicalité qui sont contraires à
l'histoire de la gauche dont je proviens
et dont mélonchon provient qui est la
gauche socialiste je crois que ça pose
un problème fondamental moral c'est rare
vous savez Cyril Hanouna quand en
politique des problèmes sepposent à
l'échelle de la morale des principes les
plus fondamentaux
elle pose pour moi la question de savoir
que font encore un certain nombre de
partis de gauche alliés de la nup et
donc de Jean-Luc Mélenchon et de la
France à ceise que font-ils vous
retravaillerz avec jeanluc Mélenchon
aujourd'hui aprs tout ça impossible
Imposs je travaillerai avec toute la
gauche qui est capable d'être pré pareil
impossible parce que des gens qui sont
aussi
habiles
dans l'incapacité de nommer simplement
des actes terroristes qui considèrent
même le Hamas après le 7 octobre comme
un mouvement de résistance en quoi la
cause palestinienne à laquelle je suis
attaché qui est une cause politique
légitime juste celle notamment de
militer pour l'existence d'un État à
côté de celui d'Israël pourquoi cette
cause juste doit être sie par des codes
antisémites par la haine par la
confusion et je vais vous dire ce qui
est plus dangereux moi je suis français
Jean-Luc Mélenchon aussi nous sommes en
France nous ne sommes pas en Israël nous
ne sommes pas à Gaza même si on
peut-être touché concerné par ce qui se
passe qui est une grande tragédie le
moment n'est pas de faire de la
l'explication géopolitique nous sommes
français et agiter les tensions jouer
sur les mauvaises passions qui peuvent
exister dans notre pays Jean-Luc
mélanchot est devenu un expert de la de
de de de ce jeu des mauvaises passions
de la conflictualisation permanente
qu'il a lui-même théorisé mais quand on
a le risque terroriste qui est le nôtre
quand on sait l'agitation que ça peut
provoquer chez un nombre d'individus
aujourd'hui radicalisés qui peuvent
passer à l'acte c'est d'une
irresponsabilité absolue ce message non
seulement est une honte mais il est
inquiétant parce que il est dangereux il
ne participe pas à ce dont nous avons le
plus besoin aujourd'hui en France la
Concorde la paix civile et je veux que
la gauche elle soit capable d'une
attitude Pacifique Jean-Luc Mélenchon a
franchi là toutes les barrières et
d'abord des barrières morales Géraldine
oui c'est pour ça que moi je suis très
contente quand j'entends par exemple
Madame garido ou Monsieur Ruffin se
désolidariser complètement de Monsieur
Mélenchon il coupe toute ambigué mais
pour revenir à ce tweet là pardonne-moi
Gill hein je je sais que tu es de tous
les combats et de tous les combats
contre les discriminations mais je te
trouve malgré tout très tendre très
conciliant parce que oui il est logique
on peut le trouver logique dans la
logique complètement comment dire
immonde et abjecte de Monsieur Mélenchon
est opportuniste mais on peut le trouver
logique mais pour autant indigne Abe
avec des un relant d'antisémitisme juste
indescriptible et là tout d'un coup je
te trouve un peu en Moonwalk sur
l'antisémitisme et je trouve que ça
enfin ça me surprend de toi ça c'est la
première chose et ensuite comme l'a dit
très justement valiré tout à l'heure il
essentialise malgré tout je trouve et il
instrumentalise je trouve les les
musulmans de France et ça je trouve que
c'est vraiment dégueulasse parce qu'en
plus il dit pour encourager le massacre
pas au nom du peuple français mais c'est
c'est pas du tout ce que dit Macron
personne ne dit ça en fait tout le monde
veut deux état et la paix alors
justement on va voir regardz ce
qu'Emmanuel Macron seendra en Israël
demain Macron va discuter de la création
d'un État palestinien et de l'AR et
l'arrêt de la colonisation c'est c'est
formidable donc deux états arrêt de la
colonisation et la paix et tout le monde
dit ça et en avec ce tweet là en fait il
jette une sorte de de troupe comme ça il
dit regardez n eux ils veulent que pas
une fois et je te le dis Gill et encore
une fois c'est catastrophique ce que tu
as dit tout à l'heure je te le dis ah
oui Mélenchon il veut qu'une chose c'est
le chos et des mecs comme toi tu
contribues à ce que Mélenchon arrive à
ce qu'il veut faire Mélenchon il ne veut
qu'une chose c'est le chaos je
t'explique si demain et c'est ce qu'on
souhaite tous il y a une paix durable
ouais euh au MoyenOrient Jean-Luc
Mélenchon sera le seul qui sera triste
et j'ai pas peur de le dire je dis je
peux dire un mot làsus arrangera pas
mais mon Gilou je te le dis parce que on
t'aime tous ici et on est comme toi on
est tous on a on a tous envie que ça se
règle voilà comme a dit le présidentain
il exactement les massacres on veut que
ça cess tous les côtés je te le dis
c'est catastrophique pour tout le monde
mais Jean-Luc Mélenchon ce que tu as pas
compris c'est que Jean-Luc Mélenchon une
fois de plus il parle pas avec son cœur
il parle pas avec sa tête il parle avec
son portefeuille de voix et ça c'est
très
grave000
surtout en ce moment et moi je j'apporte
toute ma solidarité à Yael Brod pivé qui
était très très très touché très affecté
par ce qu'il a dit Jean-Luc Mélenchon et
juste mon Gilou que tu dises euh pas un
mot sur Y Bron pivé pour moi c'est
inadmissible crois-moi c'est
inadmissible ce que tu fais après tu
fais ce que tu veux parce queici je te
je te dirais jamais de te dire un truc
ou ou autre chose et je le diraiis
jamais mais mon Gilou je te le dis
arrête moi je suis avec toi dans tous
les combats tu le sais et tu le sais
comme vraiment je suis je suis voilà tu
sais comme je veux que voilà que ça
s'arrange et que je suis dépité quand je
vois des massacres d'un côté ou de
l'autre tu le sais vraiment mais là mon
Gilou ne
pas ne pas dire un mot sur Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et dire que tu comprends ce
qu'il dit même si c'est pour expliquer
que c'est une tactique tu peux pas
démarrer comme ça excuse-moi mon Gilou
après tu dis ce que tu veux mais tu peux
pas démarrer comme ça je sa mais non
mais moi j'aurais pas fait camp mais
quand il dit au début voilà la France
c'est comme quand il a dit la République
c'est moi pour lui pour lui ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui c'est que le
gouvernement français a une politique
totalement proisraélienne et lui il
prend le contrepied en disant pourquoi
est-ce qu'on ne défend pas non pas le
Hamas mais le peuple palestini ce qui me
dérange tu veux que je te dise moi un
mec qui dit moi je vais te dire un mec
qui dit bah oui je sais pas qui défend
ses idées parce que il défend ses idées
et tous les gens qui défendent leurs
idées je les respecterai toujours plus
qu'un mec qui ne défend pas ses idées il
va
c'est pases idées jeanluc mélchon il
s'en fout totalement des Israéliens des
Palestiniens il s'en fout de toi en
premier il s'en fout de toi complètement